the fact that matter is that how people
answer will vary tremendously and it
will depend that partly as a function of
how they have defined ourselves in the
past but also the context which defines
the question is question so I'm as an
example okay one thing is that people
are much more likely to answer in ways
that reflect groups that are meaningful
to them but also they feel positive
about so for example if Canada has just
won a sporting event against the United
States people are much more likely to
say I'm Canadian but if they've just
lost a game they'd probably say
something else there will be a logic to
the way in which they answer which they
will assume what's a meaningful thing to
our so if I say who you like it if some
social function say well I'm the
president of the company or I'm the
person who signs the checks so actually
again it's this point identities create
a relation of meaning in social
interaction so you can never really
answer that question without knowing
who's asking it and in what context